Speaker 1: So I want to start today with what's
really fundamentally an infrastructure story, but
also a story about how we often sort of miss the
forest for the trees or we end up wrapped up in
a detail when the bigger story is really the big
picture. Many of you might have heard about this
bridge collapse that took place in Pittsburgh,
and because of the timing of a Joe Biden
trip to Pennsylvania, it immediately became very,
very political. We're even going to look at a clip
on Fox News of a couple of anchors there talking
about the collapse and Joe Biden's infrastructure
bill and just getting at just about every
single fact wrong. But before we get to that,
I think it's important to remind you guys that
when we talk about infrastructure and the fact
that the U.S. is woefully behind on infrastructure
spending, that infrastructure spending,
which in many countries is not political in the
U.S., is so politicized and Partizan that we have
hundreds of bridges with the exact same rating as
the Pittsburgh Bridge that collapsed. And yet we
only talk about the issue in real serious terms
when a bridge actually collapses, when we have
debates about infrastructure. It is mentioned in
passing, Hey, we have many bridges that need to be
repaired, brought back, modernized, et cetera.
But it's almost like it doesn't really exist
until there's a bridge collapse. And case
in point, there's a very good article on New
Jersey dot com NJ.com, which points out nearly 500
New Jersey bridges received the same poor rating
as the one that collapsed in Pittsburgh. And this
is for New Jersey, and it has a map so you can see
which which are nearby. But it points out on the
f h w A's national bridge inventory for 2021 482,
Garden State Bridges received a grade of
poor. That's the same rating as the bridge
in Pittsburgh's Frick Park that collapsed on
Friday morning, injuring 10 people. States,
federal agencies and tribal governments submit
data to the bridge inventory on an annual basis.
About seven percent of Jersey Bridges
have that poor grade, 27 percent are good,
which is the highest rating, and
the rest are somewhere in between.
Each bridge receives ratings on its deck,
superstructure substructure and culvert,
et cetera, et cetera. So also
important is that many of these are
railway bridges over which trains are transiting.
So obviously most of these bridges rated poor
are not going to collapse. I saw a comment from
a bridge engineer who has explained that also,
you can't always tell by looking at a bridge which
category it's in that there's lots of bridges that
look very bad cosmetically but structurally
are actually in that category. Good, even
though if you if you or I looked at it, we would
say that that's an absolute disaster. But there
Speaker 2: are
Speaker 1: lots
of these bridges with the exact same rating,
actual structural rating as the Pittsburgh Bridge
that collapsed. Now, of course, it probably won't
collapse when you or I or any one vehicle goes
over it. Usually it doesn't happen, but it reminds
us that we have a primarily reactive economy
in the United States, and this is
different than in many other countries.
There's countries where you find this,
but there's many European countries that
have a different approach in the U.S., certainly
among the right, sometimes on the left as well.
Spending money before there is a problem is seen
as imprudent. It's seen as a waste of money,
and often the money doesn't get spent until
something falls down or somebody dies first.
It's similar in health care. Why make insurance
companies cover all of this optional preventive
stuff to treat sick people? Well, no, but that's
the whole point. The optional preventive stuff
keeps people healthier on average, and it avoids
some of that big spending later. Half the country,
at least in terms of the political reality, just
doesn't accept that. Whether they believe it or
not, they don't accept it as a way to actually do
politics. And it's the exact same principle here
when it comes to these bit bridges. But bigger
picture with infrastructure spending overall,
which is when you look at that list and remember
when we just had the debate over infrastructure,
you look at that list and so many on the right
and some on the left, look at that list and they
go this stuff. It's it's not really infrastructure
spending. How is it infrastructure spending where
we are reacting to a particular storm by saying
we're going to bring all of this stuff up to
new code? That's not really recovery. That's
that's something these are pet projects. No,
it's the same principle as with health
care. And even with this, it took this
one bridge. Collapse to get people thinking in
slightly different terms about these things,
but looking just at New Jersey and you have
500 bridges with the exact same rating and
it hopefully it doesn't happen frequently, but
it's just a matter of time until it happens again